The conflict in Ukraine is only one of the
wars Vladimir Putin is fighting.
At home he’s cracked down viciously on dissent
and opposition.
Putin’s chief target in Russia has been
this man – Alexei Navalny, now in jail with
his Anti-Corruption Foundation, banned and
labelled extremist.
They’re calling on Russians to do whatever
they can to stop the war in Ukraine.
But what about the dangers in taking on the
state?
My guest this week in exile in London is one
of Navalny’s associates, Vladimir Ashurkov.
"Organized opposition in Russia that can participate
in elections, that can launch campaigns, they
can-, that can do organized mass protests
– it's really not possible at this point.
“
For now the group is naming and shaming thousands
of officials who’re supporting the war in
Ukraine – but how far will that dent Putin’s
power?
And why, despite so many common goals, are
Russian opposition groups still fighting amongst
themselves?
Vladimir Ashurkov, welcome to Conflict Zone.
It's great to be with you.
At the beginning of this month associates
of Alexei Navalny called for, what they put
it, as "a partisan underground” in Russia
to resist the war in Ukraine.
Your organization is banned, it's labeled
extremist.
So anybody who answers your call is taking
quite a risk, aren't they?
Let us put it into context: Throughout its
history Anti-Corruption Foundation and Alexei
Navalny team have been operating in Russia.
At the peak of our activities we had a regional
network of branches in over 40 cities.
We had about 200 people working for us in
Moscow.
In spring of last year our organization has
been deemed extremist and we had to relocate
all the key people outside of Russia.
Now, when the Russia started its brutal aggression
against Ukraine in February, even more restrictive
measures were put in place.
At the same time, we are constantly monitoring
what goes on in Russia, in different regions.
And over the last few months we have been
feeling that the discontent is growing and
our goal is to use our connection, our networks,
the people who used to work with us, our volunteers
to try to supplement this discontent and provide
some organizational structure.
We created a...
Yes, but as you say they, as you say, times
have changed.
Penalties have changed.
Your organization is no longer legal.
It's on a par with Islamic State.
It's been declared, you know, it's been declared
extremist.
You're asking people to spread information,
provide legal assistance.
But also, and this is the most risky part,
sabotage the work of military enlistment centers.
And the danger of getting caught doing that
is what?
There is danger in Russia now just for going
out to the street with a blank piece of paper
because the authorities assume you are protesting
against the war.
At the same time, we encourage all Russian
people inside Russia, outside of Russia, to
do their part to stop this war and to bring
down this autocratic regime of Vladimir Putin.
Everybody chooses what they do according to
their own abilities, according to their own
beliefs and appetite for risk.
But to confront this regime is, I think, a
duty of any reasonable person.
And we want to put the tools into the hands
of people who believe that they can do more
and who can do little bits and pieces, spread
out leaflets, in some cases sabotage, etc.,
etc.
It's all...
Sabotage isn't bits and pieces, is it?
...clandestine activities...
Sabotage isn't bits and pieces.
Sabotage is a pretty serious thing to get
engaged in.
Yes, but it is our goal to bring down this
regime and sabotage is one of the non-violent
instruments to do that.
So we...
How is it nonviolent sabotage?
How is it nonviolent?
People have been blowing up enlistment centers,
haven't they?
Blowing up-, I've never-, I think you're mistaken.
There has never been a blow up of an enlistment
center.
There have been...
Alright, a fire started...
There have been-, Starting fire to an enlistment
center that enlists people to fight in this
unfair and brutal war is, I think, is very
commendable.
We definitely support this activity.
And that's what we're doing.
We created a system that allows people to
remain anonymous, so we try as much as possible
to limit the risk of this network to be discovered
by authorities.
But ultimately the person decides himself
or herself what is the level of risk that
they can tolerate in fighting this brutal
regime.
Your organization has been clear that the
Russian people aren't simply going to overthrow
Putin.
It's just not going to happen.
So, so in the grand scheme of things, the
kind of resistance you're asking for: Can
that justify the risks you're asking people
to take?
I think the change in Russia will come from
a combination of dissatisfaction in the political
and business elite of Russia and the wide
discontent in the population.
And both of these groups of people were having
a quite a hard time since the war started.
People at the top have seen their fortunes
decimated, their lifestyles - when they can
vacation in Western Europe, when their children
go to British private schools, when their
yachts are moored in Italy - has been shattered.
And for an average person, they have seen
inflation, they have seen familiar foreign
brands leaving Russia.
And now they see a constant stream of coffins
coming back from Ukraine.
And for what?
The military operation has not been going
very successfully for Russian army.
So, these processes take time, but at some
point they will reinforce each other.
And that's, I think, the only plausible scenario
for change.
You talk about people seeing coffins returning
from the war.
People are also seeing hundreds put in jail,
many facing 15-year sentences for resisting
in the most trivial ways.
Maybe they once gave money to an organization
like yours that's now banned.
Police informers everywhere.
Who knows how many may have penetrated your
organizations?
What's been the response to your call for
this "partisan underground"?
We are basing our efforts on more than a decade
of work in Russia in different regions.
Before the war started we had over 10 million
subscribers to different, different social
networks that were broadcasting our message.
We had an email distribution list of over
a million people.
So, we are not starting from scratch.
And obviously we, for understandable reasons,
we don't disclose the response and we don’t
disclose the scale of these activities.
But we are quite optimistic.
The response has been dozens of thousands
of people who would like to participate in
this network.
Mr. Ashurkov, one of your most ambitious ventures
has been to compile a list of 6000 Russians
said to be bribe takers, warmongers, corrupt
officials, propagandists, people you accuse
of enabling the invasion of Ukraine.
Are you not concerned that this is the equivalent
of sort of painting a target on their back
and encouraging people to shoot at them?
Indeed, there have been many people who are
the pillars of this regime.
People who are involved in war propaganda,
people who are officials in various levels
of Russian government, businessmen connected
to Putin's regime, his cronies.
And the-, for years our team has been advocating
sanctions, personal sanctions against perpetrators
of human rights abuses, against people involved
in corruption.
But our calls have been falling on deaf ears.
It has been a trickle in terms of sanctions,
even after the Russian annexation of Crimea
and meddling in eastern Ukraine.
Now, after the war, we've seen an avalanche
of sanctions and it was important for us to
make suggestions to Western governments to
make their sanctions policy more nuanced.
And we came up with this list that we advocate
and we lobby various Western governments that
these people are included.
They are people who have contributed to the
start of the war and who are now continuing
to support the war.
That's-, that has been the sort of the premise
of our project, and it has received quite
good support from the governments in the EU,
in the US and the UK.
Just recently there was a resolution passed
in US House of Representatives calling for
the executive branch to review the 200 most
visible, the top priority 200 people from
our list in terms of sanctioning them in the
US.
So I think it's working.
One important aspect of our list is....
I want to ask you- Yes, just...
Sure.
Just, briefly just briefly.
By September, five months after you went public,
there are only some 50 people on the list
who had contacted you and asked to be taken
off it.
Are you surprised that the vast majority seemed
completely untroubled by your accusations
and just ignored the shaming?
The actual number is over 100...
Out of 6.000.
...and it's mostly...
Out of, out of 6.000, indeed.
It's not many, is it?
It's not many.
To me, anything that's above zero-, If a person
changes his or her mind in terms of support
of the war, in terms of being part of the
government structures, being on the board
of Russian state-owned companies, that's already
a lot because without our list, this number
would be zero.
So, it has been over 100.
We are constantly reviewing this list.
Every two weeks there are some updates.
We take people out if there are reasons to
believe that they don't-, that they no longer
qualify for being on the list.
We make additions.
And specifically the nature of our list is
that we want to use it not as much as an instrument
of punishment, but as an instrument of coercion
so that less people support the war and contribute
to it.
So for instance, if we take Western sanctions,
it has been a one-way ticket.
A person, an official or a businessman is
sanctioned and there is nothing they can do
that can remove them from this list.
With us, it's different.
If you're on the board of a state company,
if you resign or if you are in the top management
of a state company, agency or organization
resign, send us proof of that and we'll review
it and we'll take you out.
So..
Okay.
All right.
...our list is live.
To date, you're the best-known opposition
group in Russia and you’ve had some remarkable
successes.
You lifted the lid on a huge amount of corruption,
you've shown films, Putin's Palace, for instance.
You've named names and reported on wide ranging
corruption.
12 million views a month on YouTube, something
like that.
But what sign is there that any of that has
materially affected Putin's support in the
country?
Navalny has said Putin is afraid of the truth,
but Putin simply shrugs off your truth as
‘fake news’.
What's he got to be afraid of?
It's not easy to fight an oppressive regime
like Putin's.
We have been doing it for a number of years.
There are some objective benchmarks how you
can judge a successful political movement.
I think the most objective result was the
results of elections of Moscow mayor in 2013
when Alexei Navalny was able to participate.
That's sort of an objective measure, the results
of an election.
So he got 28% of votes as opposed to 51 for
the incumbent mayor.
So, and that was despite all the administrative
obstacles that we had, despite Navalny being
a sort of a newcomer, despite the incumbent
mayor having all the sources, all the resources
that the power was able to give him.
So...
This was nine years ago.
Mr. Ashurkov.
I'm talking about now.
Everything has changed since then.
Everything has changed.
What has Putin got to be afraid of now?
Navalny is in jail and your organization is
banned and labelled extremist.
What's he got to be afraid of?
As I said, it will be the wide discontent
in population and the disillusionment with
the regime in the elite.
If you-, even if you talk about close circle
of Putin, they are really not happy with the
state of affairs.
They are afraid of Putin and of his security
apparatus.
But they, of course, would like to go back
to how things were and they were able to enjoy
their wealth, they were integrated in the
West and they were able to enjoy the lifestyle
that they were used to.
Now it's all broken.
And that's what Putin needs to be afraid.
There is a big factor, of course, what happens
on the battlefields of Ukraine.
And...
All right, I want to come to that.
I want to come to that a little later.
But I want to talk also about the opposition
movement in general in Russia.
And plenty of people have talked about the
disunity that seems to attend these groups.
Why hasn't your organization put more effort
into improving relations with other opposition
groups?
After all, you share quite a few goals, don't
you, with each other?
Indeed, we have been working with various
democratic political forces for years.
We created the Coordination Council in 2012.
We participated in a number of elections together
with different other democratic forces...
But that didn't always work out, did it?
I mean, it ended up-, you ended up squabbling
with other groups.
I remember in 2021-, when was the last election,
2021, the opposition member Anastasia Bryukhanova,
she said the opposition can't be united, a
liberal can't agree with a nationalist or
a communist.
It's simply impossible.
It's a big drawback, this kind of disunity,
isn't it?
Not really.
The people who make real effort at trying
to do something useful and not just talk,
they achieve successes.
We are in contact with various opposition
groups.
But the thing that made Navalny and our organization
successful - and we increase our recognition
and we are able to create the regional networks
and we are able now to keep dozens of people
in our office outside of Russia - is that
we focus just on a few things.
We do investigations, we do media work.
Our YouTube channels are probably the most
popular current news sources in Russia.
And now we're restoring this work in Russia
through our regional network.
And we have a certain hierarchy.
We have about 70 people, mostly in Vilnius,
in a few other European cities as well, who
work full-time on this.
And for us to join forces with somebody, there
has to be a goal.
The other parties need to bring something
to the table.
It's not enough just to be a blogger with
50,000 followers to be able to join forces
with us and to have equal voices in what we
do.
Mr. Ashurkov, do you ever foresee a time when
Navalny or your group could possibly emerge
again as a serious political contender on
Russia's national stage?
I ask because Vladimir Milov, a former minister
and economic adviser to Navalny, said last
week that Russia's organized opposition is
destroyed.
There is no mechanism, he said, for public
discontent to translate into political change.
Can you honestly tell me he's wrong?
Well, I think he's right...
He's one of your-, he's one of your closest
advisers.
Absolutely.
But you always need to put words in the context.
Indeed, if you protest openly against the
war and against Putin's brutality in Russia,
you will be fined, you will be detained and
ultimately you will be jailed.
That's the situation.
So in this sense, organized opposition in
Russia that can participate in elections,
that can launch campaigns, they can-, that
can do organized mass protests - it's really
not possible at this point.
But the millions of people who supported us,
who supported other democratic forces, many
of whom who had to move out of Russia, they
didn't go anywhere.
And once the political situation in Russia
change - a gradual liberalization and end
of hostilities with Ukraine and start of some
sort of communication with the West in a constructive
way - once that starts, and I believe that
it will start within the next five years,
maybe even earlier, I think there will be
a opening for us and for other democratic
forces to enter the Russian politics properly
to...
If the war is as long and bitter as some people
fear, what do you think that will do to Russia?
You've said you think there might be an end
to hostilities over the next five years.
Do you see any sign of deep and abiding changes
taking place in the country as a result of
this war?
Different people believe in different things.
In terms of war, from where we sit today it's
difficult to envision that the war will end
in the next few months.
I think it's something like a year, in a year
I think is a reasonable prediction that the
hostilities will stop.
The...
Why?
Based on what?
What makes you say that?
I think within a year it's reasonable to expect
that Ukrainian army will make a few more significant
advances on the battlefield.
We see that the Russian military capabilities
are deteriorating while Ukraine's capability
and the flow of arms and coordination is improving.
They are already bold enough to launch attacks
in the sort of-, in the jewel of Russian Navy
in Sevastopol naval base in Crimea.
So I think the military...
And you think Russia is just going to give
up in the end and go home?
Militarily-, That's not what I said.
I'm saying that the military capabilities,
the balance of power is shifting to Ukraine,
and we will see that manifesting itself on
the battlefield.
The economic sanctions placed on Russia will
be taking their gradual toll.
The-, and of course, the losses from the Ukrainian
front are taking-, are affecting the mood
of Russian public.
So I think in a year these processes would
lead to possibly - and again, we're all speaking
in probabilities and possibilities here - to
Russia's inability to continue the war.
That's my prediction.
Alright.
Vladimir Ashurkov, it's been good to have
you on the program.
Thank you very much indeed for being on Conflict
Zone.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.